first one we've got here is Gilly
malinsky
who is uh frustrated and quitting I
always like to consider the source
whenever I have an opportunity to take a
look at an article
so this links me to her Twitter
this is Gilly here
another easy way to check out what
you're looking at is just hit the media
tab on Twitter and you usually see some
photographs so
just nothing
spectacular obviously but uh you know
somebody would obviously have an
interest
um
so let's get into what she said she says
in April I made a decision I deleted
hinge uh it was the last of the dating
apps left on my phone so in addition to
hinge I've tried Tinder Bumble the
league if you're not familiar I think
the league is the one where um you have
to qualify to get in it's uh like a high
status account
uh dating account I'm not sure how she'd
qualify for that as a writer though but
I guess it's got to be high status for
dudes women you know just come on in uh
JDate and I've spent uh likely hundreds
of hours scouring them in hopes of
finding that coveted long-term
relationship but I'm still single and
I'm so tired
what a first let's
cut this up a little bit here
what at first seemed like a fun low
stakes way to engage with the wild world
of dating turn into a frustrating and
soul-sucking chore well does that sound
familiar to you guys I've heard you guys
say that quite a bit
uh after five fruitless years I'll only
be dating in the real world from now on
okay her success rate is only four
percent which to be honest with you I
mean if you're like
if you're a dude and you're a seven out
of ten four percent's a good success
rate
um you're a nine or a ten guy you're
gonna have a much higher success rate
because that's those are all the guys
that all the women want
um but this I don't know you guys rate
her you guys rate her in the comments
you tell me what you think she is uh
that's obviously one of the better
photographs of her because the ones that
we were looking on the Twitter timeline
they they just didn't pack the same
punch
um so four percent success rate I really
didn't dive until 2017 when I started to
give Tinder a month-long trial I packed
in two to three dates a week over the
course of a month at the time the whole
thing was pretty novel and exciting who
are these strangers making passes on my
phone
so I decided to keep going over the last
five years so she's been a five years
I've been five years fifty dates that
doesn't add up
if she's doing three dates a week let's
do the math here
it's mine already times 52 that's 156
dates a year
times five years at 780 dates if if
she's doing three a week for five years
so over the last five years I've been at
least 50 dates with 50 different guys I
think I click with maybe five of them
and ended up dating two for several
months wait did she say she talked to
three guys a week or had three dates a
week I packed in two to three dates a
week over the course of a month okay
well maybe she only had one good month
anyway
um then I think I clicked to maybe five
of them ended up dating two for several
months okay
if we take the ladder to be a success
that's a four percent uh success rate
depressingly low odds which is common
for most guys I mean like even if you're
a seven out of ten four percent is
probably going to be pretty decent you
know four five six something like that
uh it doesn't mean I think it's
impossible to meet somebody great on a
dating app these days online dating is
the most popular way for heterosexual
couples in the US to meet according to
2019 study by researchers at Stanford
University and the University of New
Mexico but I personally have not had
such luck me me
what I found on these apps instead is
frustration from all the wasted effort
Fury that is really
that it really works for me dread that
it won't ever work for me and generally
feeling a feeling of burnout no I'm not
alone nearly 45 percent of Americans who
use dating apps or websites in the
previous year said they experience left
left them feeling more frustrated Pew
Center researcher 4 860 adults
so she goes on to say it's like hitting
a slot machine I wonder what that means
and it sorry in talking to friends and
reading various media about modern
dating I found that people have all
sorts of legitimate gripes matches won't
respond textures ghosts people get nudie
photos they didn't ask well matches
won't respond to Texas ghost is like
most of what most guys will deal with on
dating apps if they're not high value
like like I said even a six or seven out
of ten is going to get super frustrated
very fast
uh for me regardless of how real a
person's photos are or how accurate his
description or how Earnest he is in
texting no digital profile could ever
possibly represent the whole person
should write about that in real life
always trumps uh it can't even represent
the majority of a person Tech is too
flat superficial limiting in space to
capture someone that's a lot of blah
blah blah for I couldn't get a lot of
matches that like me back
am I right
I know you guys tell me in the live
comments plus crucial these apps can't
predict chemistry only meeting up can
give a sense of both what person's like
and if you click what I found going out
with these 50 guys again 50 guys
I got 780 using her math of three a week
how do you go from 50 to 780 or how do
you go from 780 down to 50.
if I encountered them in life before
swiping or liking or texting I would
have known I wasn't interested I would
have known that there is no spark well
they would have known the same thing too
sweetheart because a lot of the times
when guys look at Women's pictures they
are not an accurate representation of
what guys meet in real life it's very
rare that a woman looks as advertised
when met in real life they're usually
not not even close older photography
filters there's all kinds of reasons for
that but you guys you guys know right
I'm trying to look at this from the
woman's perspective so she's not getting
a lot of matches again it's a lot of
blah blah blah from not getting guys
that like me back
um I would have known I wasn't
interested no spark okay think of it
like hitting a slot machine it says
Devin Simone dating coach and Senior
Matchmaker a three-day rule the odds of
meeting someone in the apps do people
win a slot machines absolutely how many
times okay well let's just plug for her
whatever it is so oh she's 36. shocking
right uh You Can't Hurry Love is the
title of this segment I'm trying to be
more intentional about how I spend my
time as evidence of this kind of
attitude improves well-being and the
more intentional I get the less in
patience I have for optional activities
that make it pretty miserable including
online dating they're just not worth it
again a lot of words for I'm not getting
guys to like me back
I've been sorry it's been five months
since I do sorry it's a lot of words for
the guys that I like that are handsome
that don't like me back I just want to
be clear about that
now instead of swiping and chatting with
these guys whose Vibes I can't Gage and
meeting up to force a conversation I'm
catching up with my grandma or reading
plays okay
uh regular frustrations I got covered a
few weeks ago okay Cry Me a River but
it's devoid this is a recent article too
what are you still talking about covet
for September 17th this is in the last
couple weeks by the way if you guys want
to send me articles like this I mean
most you already do it this way anyway
the about link on my channel has my
email address it's just entrepreneurs
and cars gmail.com
um I usually just sort of kind of
collect them and I'll do a video on
similar articles around the same time
sort of thing we're doing here tonight
with the other twos
uh kovid but devoid of drudgery
scrolling through random profiles I'm
scared of not ever meeting someone as a
result of this move
oh man
this is like uh this is probably I mean
I'd have to take a look at some of the
conversations and the matches but she
doesn't have them anything here but it's
like I don't know judging by the
photograph and what we saw on uh Twitter
it's probably a a matter of lowering
expectations is generally what it boils
down to for uh women they just have the
highest expectations and they they want
dudes to take off every box and it's
like
I don't know like what do you bring to
the table you know you bring
some pronouns in your bio
you've worked for a whole bunch of
magazines I don't know New York Times
MTV News Vice okay well that's probably
why you're definitely leaning in the
wrong direction for the kinds of guys
you probably want
I don't know like like if a chick had a
picture like that on her dating profile
you're not going to get any matches from
high value dudes they're not going to
want to hang out with that
there's not much else in here those are
the only pictures I see but anyway is
what it is so Gil Gilly is quitting
because she only had a four percent
success rate which is
pretty much the experience that most
guys have that are not chats
um it's like digging for gold you're
gonna have to dig through a lot of dirt
to find somebody and get a decent match
and even then uh probably not gonna be
what you're expecting let's go to the
next article here so we've got
um single mom uh sorry she says I'm a
single mom and nobody will ever come
before my kids
how many times have you seen that as a
uh bio description right how do you know
in the live chat
by Katie Smith what are we dealing with
here
uh
do we have uh I don't know what is this
link to
Facebook and Instagram
oh this is a business page instead of a
personal page
what is she really I guess this is her
over here with her kids
looking all boss boss babe out with her
laptop
all right well this is you know this is
our girl here and uh three kids three
years crafts her ass off in order to
stay sane left to right wear faux
leather pants eat at burger joints and
make beautiful things okay she pays her
kids to rub her feet so let's let's read
her article about why she's quitting and
putting her kids first
okay let's get rid of these pop-ups here
come on scram there we go
uh after my divorce five years ago my
three teenagers told me time and time
again that they were fine if I dated
somebody took me a while but when I got
out there again they love to hear about
my dates and I picked them up from their
father's house the next day imagine
picking up your kids from their father's
house all three of them and you're
telling them about your weekends
running around
here we go uh sometimes we had a good
laugh about them but mostly if they
sense I like someone they were anxious
and wanted to meet them right away
despite the fact I had a six months rule
I'm assuming the six months rule is not
okay here we go I only let them meet
someone if we've been exclusive for six
months exclusive okay because you're a
prize exclusive
how old is this lady
I don't know she looks like she's late
30s early 40s early 40s probably
and she's and she's selling uh Purity
right now I'll be exclusive you with you
I'll be pure uh it was important to me
to feel like they were going to be in my
life for a while before I let them into
our family so letting again you know you
have to enter her frame you have to
enter her family you know it's not a
there's no consideration about what what
he might have going on but anyway
I've done my best along the way uh I've
really stumbled into a world of dating
and reducing some of my kids I didn't
know what to expect or how I could fit a
man into our lives because the truth is
they wouldn't just be dating me they
would walk into a family of four who had
already established a very tight Bond
yeah you're an outsider it's like you're
not going to be included you're not
you're not ever going to be part of the
tribe anytime soon anyway
um you're just signing up for a lot of
guys say this you know playing somebody
else's saved game
um but there you have it so the type
Bond I quickly learned that getting into
a relationship with your kids involved
and having them meet your kids are two
entirely different experiences no matter
how strong your you feel the
relationship is Jesus these pop-ups
the first man I dated post divorce was
younger than me and didn't have any
children well
okay you're gonna have problems with
that sweetheart
he was very receptive to the fact that I
had three he's probably beta he's got to
be a beta no no guy with any dignity
would do this
he was very receptive to the fact that I
had three kids and wanted to meet them a
lot sooner than he did yeah definitely I
thought this would be the perfect
Arrangement because we only had one set
of kids to be content with to contend
with
but I was wrong he didn't understand why
I couldn't just go out on a random
Friday night when I had my children he
didn't get to know some nights that I
didn't have my kids sorry he didn't get
how some nights when I didn't have my
kids I just needed time to refuel and
often wanted to stay in and get a good
night's sleep he didn't understand why I
couldn't cater him in the way that his
previous girlfriends who didn't have
kids had
yeah
um if a guy is going to sign up for a
relationship with a woman he's looking
for a relationship he's looking for a
woman to compliment his life and enter
his frame and be available and want to
you know see him sort of thing and she's
already starting this article with well
my the first man that I dated post
divorce was younger than me and didn't
have any kids so we've got this I don't
know early 40s check I'm assuming dating
a guy 5 10 15 years younger who the hell
no she didn't say his age and he doesn't
understand what she's dealing with in
her life and he truthfully probably
doesn't care and he shouldn't have to
care but she wants him to care
and like it's already destined to fail
it's like every single single mommy
story right he didn't want my kids or
not
for a while I tried but I fizzled fast
and realized it was killing me to give
him everything he needed be fun not fall
asleep on the sofa on a date night
before nine be spontaneous for a weekend
getaway and shuffling around my kids
schedule asking my ex to take on nights
come on another pop-up
uh we're go to be spontaneous take out
nicely rescheduled to be with me it was
nearly impossible I felt like I was
failing as their mom I had less energy I
wasn't able to well you didn't want to
make it work with the kid's father why
would you want to make it work with some
random dude that's younger than you with
no kids that your kids don't have any
real connection with anyway
I wasn't able to remember the school
activities honestly I wasn't my best
self because I didn't have enough time
to tend to my own needs which was a huge
part of being a mommy you can't pour
from an empty cup after all so I pulled
back and told myself I had to reevaluate
my time and that I needed to be a mother
first
there it is my kids will always come
first you guys have seen it
I've got four little superhumans or some
[ __ ] like that right
nobody cares no real man cares anyway
but a real man would step up and be the
father that stepped up
nope clearly she's having problems with
that anyway
mother first you seem fine with that x
uh feeling a mom
damn pop-ups keeps moving my thing
around after after that excapate I
decided I would only date dads
surely they would understand my
lifestyle more right wrong
let's see what happens now my next
relationship was with a dad yet he
seemed to have the same problems he'd
understand why I couldn't ask see one of
the problems that guys have
even if you're a dad is that women get
custody orders 80 of the time and that
means they've got the kids pretty much
all the time with the exception of every
other weekend and usually like a
Wednesday night or something like that
that's usually how the how most of the
deals go so that means even if you're
dating a dad he's going to end up
spending more time with some other mofos
kids than his own kids and he's going to
have some expectations since he's got
you know freedom because his wife is or
his ex-wife has taken the kids more
often than not and most of his money
flows to her he's going to have some
expectations and you're not gonna be
able to meet them because you're too
exhausted because you generally have
most of the custody
anyway uh same problems he didn't
understand why I couldn't ask my kid's
father to take them more so we could go
on vacate there it is right you know she
obviously has more custody than he does
he wanted to go on vacations and do
stuff and uh she didn't want to uh do
that because it would require schedule
changes and custody changes and stuff
like that and I would imagine if that
changes too often then there's going to
be some money that she's going to lose
that he'll end up gaining if he's got
the kids more because of his demands to
go on vacations she doesn't talk about
that though right like you know she's
not being honest here in this article
he wanted more time alone with me and
without our kids he wanted me to stay at
his house on nights he didn't have any
kids but my oldest son was at home my
son was old enough to be by himself but
he insisted
and sure he was but that wasn't a point
he didn't get to sorry he didn't seem to
get that I didn't care about the
nightlife for going out I cared about
spending that time with my kids so it's
all about kids so why are you dating
because I can't get it back it would be
different if I had full custody of them
but I don't I don't get to see them all
the time oh boy
they went there with me they come before
anyone else
ultimately this relationship ended after
a few years and I realized something if
putting my kids first has to mean I'll
be single I'm okay well no you're not
because you're bitching about it in an
article here right now I thought I'd be
with my kids father forever but that
didn't end up happening how do I know my
next relationship
I'm in will last I mean don't I don't
the truth is no one can have that kind
of insurance but the one thing that I do
know is that I've got three because I
still need me so all my children so
you're going to spend all your time with
teenagers that you think need you even
though you've got spare time alone but
then you're gonna [ __ ] about not having
a guy or you know because you're putting
your kids first
I guarantee this chick's running some
fwbs right now that's all she's doing
they have time to get they have sorry
they get to have me first that means if
they're sick even though they're yeah
this is all virtue single and it's all
posturing they need me for emotional
support I'll make that yeah okay do
things on vacation Night Away
my experience with dating as a single
mother has given me further proof that
most of the relationship load fails on
the mother load fail falls on the mother
sorry uh no it doesn't
no it does not that is that is a bizarre
statement to make my experience with
dating as a single mother has given me
further proof that most of the
relationship load falls on the mother
dude is trying to like take you on a
vacation
um organizing that and there's no
collaboration on that me me I'm a victim
uh we have expected to be the caretakers
for the kids uh no you have not fathers
are very happy to be caretakers for the
children but moms generally don't let
them because they want the custody so
they can get control and get the money I
covered that in my book by the way
there's at least it's it's covered on
the chapter on dating single mommies
um even in the marriage chapter like
you'll understand the dynamic
differences and it's not good or bad it
just is what it is right it's not you
know it's not a bug it's a feature of
the Dynamics between men and women when
you understand and then you know how to
deal with them better
we have expected to go sorry we expected
to excel professionally be independent
look amazing and not let ourselves go
whatever that means it means don't get
fat uh and then we get into a
relationship we're expected to make our
man feel important enough so that he
doesn't feel neglected or left out yeah
correct that's that's why it's called a
relationship like why would he be
exclusive with you why would he abandon
his sexual strategy be exclusive with
you if you're not giving him what he
needs lady like come on and then you're
wondering why it's not working out
uh so she's complaining that she's
expected to be a professional be
independent look amazing like
and then deal with the whole
relationship component like the first
two there Excel professionally and be
independent that's a lie that you know
Society sold you that's that's toxic
feminism that's the Matrix whatever it
is you want to call it
uh but you don't want to do the work to
manage relationship Sean said you you
read an article to complain about and
why you're going to put your kids first
anyway I can tell you from experience
it's an impossible feat and I'm more
than happy to let go of all the nonsense
do what feels right for me because the
truth is my love life can wait but my
kids can't
invest in Pet Food guys cat food dog
food you know the little fluffy white
dogs stuff like that
this uh this is who this is uh selling
to hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out